[Music]
time now for final exam where you see
which figures in the news have been
doing their jobs and paying attention
our first contestant this week is Fox
News at night host shannon bream who is
a perfect even no record though of
course you knew that here's a roster of
the people she's vanquished in recent
months bill hemmer bret baier brian
kilmeade
and henry Peter Doocy mark Stein jillian
turner and our friend Griff Jenkins his
Fox politics editor Chris star while the
winner if it's Chris Tarrant Walt gets
the coveted mouth-breathing Shannon will
get the airplane sized bottle of green
champagne for hands on buzzers I'm going
to ask the questions the first
contestant to buzzing gets to answer you
must wait til I finish asking the
question order to do that each correct
answer is worth one point you get it
wrong you lose a point best of five wins
are you ready sir standing question one
this is easy it's winter the East Coast
is getting pounded by an extreme weather
system which is unleashing Blizzard like
conditions the name of this weather
system is characteristically overheated
as is often the case in meteorology what
are they calling this weather system
shannon bream Grayson Grayson is your
answer that's the name of the storm
right do I get I don't know if that's
true I'm gonna have to go to the tension
and tens of millions of Americans on the
East Coast are being pummeled by a
winter storm that's being called a bomb
cyclone breaking news a winter bomb
cyclone as it is called bearing down on
40 million people in America so-called
bomb cyclone taking aim with
hurricane-force winds we're seeing the
beginning of that winter bomb cyclone I
didn't coin the phrase bomb cyclone this
area of low pressure is going to undergo
something called Bombo Genesis
you said what was it called this may be
a case of you knowing too much and being
too precise because you are an attorney
after all but we're gonna have to go
with a colloquial term bomb cyclone and
crazy sorry this is giving you a sense
me now I see how you I see how you guys
just follow the orders Gaming the
selection - you've got four more
questions for doing yourself first
responders rushed to the property of
before a president and first lady after
a fire broke out in the bedroom
whose property wasn't your start well
Bill and Hillary Clinton Hillary Clinton
was it built in Hillary Clinton to the
tape we go firefighters rushing to the
home of Bill and Hillary Clinton a small
fire breaking out on the second floor of
a Secret Service facility on their
property in Chappaqua New York north of
Manhattan but the house is actually
known as Grayson your role here but
suddenly I'm rooting for you I'm not
sure what I know and I never thought I
would feel that way but I'm with America
on this question three CNN under fire
for an odd segment a tear to new year's
oh boy one of its reporters appearing to
smoke marijuana on a party bus through
which kind of device Shannon bring a
bong says shannon bream is shannon bream
an expert on marijuana questions like
this - the tape we go maybe I would
bring a gas mask with me so I wouldn't
you know get that contact hi the other
end of the gas man yes a bong and of
course they couldn't stand to see a bong
that didn't have any cannabis in its I
don't think this is really what a gas
mask is used for by
Wow okay this is New Year's Eve dimers
so the answer we're looking for was gas
masks but as our judges just pointed out
there's a bomb it was a bomb shannon
bream was right just like shitstorm was
called Gracie so we're back next
question is why did the gyro in the zoo
because I got ripped off one is zero
okay which celebrity host is now in a
feud with Eric Trump after Eric Trump
suggested she was a member of the deep
state celebrity television host in a
fight with Eric trump he says she's a
member of the deep state she's a
comedian a comedienne she has a
television show I don't move some people
call it the new Oprah I don't but some
do Whoopi Goldberg is it Whoopi Goldberg
my name was trending because of this
trauma suggests that Ellen DeGeneres is
part of the deep stage apparently Eric
tried to trick him into following
liberals apparently I'm part of some
secret government conspiracy called
the deep state it's just the craziest
thing I've seen all week because I saw
that movie with the lady having sex with
a fish and still this beats that what I
didn't see that movie that was not a
good tour I don't think it's what we
Goldberg no I'm not sure but I don't
think so I don't think I don't think all
right final final question oh my lord
this will be a fast one so be ready okay
and you BA he may know the answer which
senator announced he is retiring this
year possibly paving the way for Mitt
Romney to run for his seat shannon bream
corn hat that can't be right orrin hatch
retiring I don't II what I going to
leave I mean what got this wrong I think
it's Chris Dodd ballistic Grayson well
the longest serving Republican senator
Orrin Hatch will not seek re-election
this year the 83 year old lawmaker from
Utah announcing his retirement after
serving since 1977 1977 were you alive
that barely I don't think since Bjorn
Borg
pulled himself off the court of
Wimbledon the late 70s to never come
back like that
Shannon bring don't feel bad it was in a
car don't you get our airplane sighs
champagne enjoy it it's delicious know
what I always do Chris tyre well you
really weren't worthy opponent I think I
did what I could
Chris Chris Grayson that concludes this
week's final exam be sure to pay as much
attention to the news as shannon bream
does and shoot in each thursday to see
if you can beat her